it's true have you you're hilarious by
the way and I love your eye makeup right
now oh my honey I was on theme I know
yeah but you look like you're ready no
like rock and roll like ready for a show
I understood the assignment honey I
absolutely did I understood the I love
it so your your new movie um it's based
on Chinese mythology yes yes I love
mythology in general I don't know a ton
about Chinese mythology so what so The
tig's Apprentice uh exclusively Prem in
on Paramount plus February 2nd is uh
this mystical adventure of a young
Warrior who who kind of just goes on a
wild ride with the characters the
Chinese zodiac um animals yeah and are
you familiar with that it's like the
year of the Rat the year of the dog I'm
the Year of the Dog I think I play you
are the Year of the Dog I researched
this actually I was ready to go but you
already knew yes um I'm the year of the
snake 1989 1989 I'm pretty much I'm the
Chinese Tor Swift
say those yeah um that's what I I was
thinking when you walked in that's what
everyone thinks but no one like talks
about it enough so weird so I play the
monkey in this film and it's just so fun
the star studded cast of Henry Golding
Sandra o Lucy Lou Michelle yo need I say
more Bowen Yang Leah Lewis
randu who went to the same high school
as me it's just like this it's a dream
come true it's a vision board moment for
sure great cast yeah yeah but you were
also in radio I didn't know that yes you
have a great voice even your yes yes yes
well how did you get into radio so you
know I wanted to do it all really and I
after years which we can which we are
honey money um and in college I did a
little bit of Campus radio so after I
graduated I got a job at 971 FM yeah on
the street team that's where you got to
start and cut to me starting to do stand
up in 2016 and like making funny videos
Carson Daly who was the morning show
host at at amp radio at the time caught
wind of me and was like why are we not
using her so he literally invites me in
to meet with me and he put me on the
morning show you know just do some funny
bits here and there and like I always
say that Carson Dy gave me my first big
break do you are you still in contact
with him I never got his phone number
you know hey I am friends with Carson
would you I think we should call him can
we call him now let's call him let's
call him let's call
him thanks yes yes yes okay wait I'm
gonna call him Carson da I I love Carson
he's one of my favorite people I've ever
I get lost in those blue eyes what's up
tasty oh my
God wait I am Sher here what's up Sherry
how are you am I going to cry you should
Carson I made it oh my gosh of course
you made it look at you Sherry you're
the best I'm so happy for all of your
success this is the coolest story my God
what what are your first impressions of
me I have to know oh my gosh I mean you
were on my radio show years ago you did
this character called Lil tasty I
laughed so hard we always knew how
talented you were so it's not a surprise
that you've made it big time I really I
tell everyone that Carson Daly gave me
my first big break well I don't know
about that Sher that's sweet but yeah
I'm psyched that I've gotten to know you
this long and just well it looks like
when I left your life things really
started to ramp up for you so it's a
good thing I'm happy for you thank you
so much for everything I'll see you soon
all right Sherry keep up the great work
thanks Kell this would be the funnest
crew at a bar just saying or barmageddon
there we go we can come on your show
totally you guys got to come on Blake
and I would love to have you on barmag
black out together I want to play yeah I
want to play against Sherry next time
I'll kick her ass
too a threat it's booked we'll have you
guys on thanks so much we love you all
right love you Carson bye love you guys
congrats Sherry bye Kelly bye everybody
everybody I love him I have Goosebumps
and here's the thing I don't do that I
don't call people on a show ever but
he's one of the people that is like cool
that you're like no no he'll he'll be
like cool with it you know I literally
he's so cool I'm so grateful that was so
[Music]
[Applause]
special thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home